[Music]
early on in ursula kayla green's sixth
earth sea novel we're going to see the
importance of one of the characters
tahanu who is formerly named theroux in
the fourth novel to hanu in the last
chapter of which it's revealed that she
is herself a dragon she is called
daughter by the oldest of all dragons
coalescing and she's going to play a
very important role in this sixth
earthsea novel as well by this time she
is no longer just a girl she's somebody
in her 20s she's coming with her mother
tenar
at the behest of the king to give them
some advice about the issues that
they're facing with the dragons and some
other things are going to get mixed in
there as well already very early on
at the council and at the court we find
that alder brings a message from gad
that turns out not to really be a
message as as such but rather a
set of questions and enigma
about
um you know the dry land and who goes
there and about the wall of stones so
she's she's given these questions and
then they start to talk about the
dragons as well and
one of the things
that is being asked of her
is
what she can in fact
do
and this comes up
in the discussion that they're having
before the king asks her something
there's a story about the dragon or the
also the girl who will uh be called orm
irian and um
[Music]
tahanu says call her oh call her
and she says this to alder
rather to the to the wizard onyx and
tenor says what is it what is it tehanu
and tahanu stares around them call her
here she looked at the king can you call
her and the king says i i don't have any
such power maybe the pattern of rook
maybe you yourself and tahanu says no no
no i am not like her
i have no wings and this is
you know just a simple sentence but it's
something that is fraught with many
implications she is one of the dragon
kind but she doesn't have wings and
we're going to find out that wings turn
out to be something quite important
later on we also know from the story of
the woman of kameh that there were in
fact winged human beings and so
lebanon says
you know i can't do anything about this
tenor tahana turns around faces the king
and says i'm sorry i have to be alone
i'll think about what my father said
i'll try to answer what he asked but i
have to be alone
and then a little bit later
she is going to be asked by the king to
do
several things
so
the first thing is he says that
tahanu it may be that you alone in my
kingdom can help me
if you can call these dragons
call to these dragons as you called to
coalescing if you have any power over
them if you can speak to them and ask
why they war on my people will you
do so so can you bring these dragons
here to to speak with us so we can find
out why they're attacking
our
farms and villages and what we find
interestingly enough is so the young
woman shrank from his words turning
towards her mother right as she did when
she was a little girl
tenor did not offer her any shelter she
stood on moving after a while she said
tahanu long ago i told you when a king
speaks to you you answer you were a
child then and didn't answer you're not
a child now so what we're getting to see
in this
is tehanu being pushed into
real adulthood and it's it's a
not adulthood like most of us face it's
one that has some incredible demands so
tahanu says
i can't call to them i don't know them
lebanon says can you call coalescing she
shook her head too far away i don't know
where
and then tener said but you are
colessian's daughter can you not speak
to these dragons and she says i don't
know
so
tahanu doesn't know her own capabilities
she doesn't know whether she can
help the situation
now things start to take another turn
and
another question gets asked
of her one that was already being
formulated but now is being made
explicit
lebanon says
if there is any chance to hanu that
they'll talk to you that you can talk to
them
i beg you to take that chance
for i can't fight them and don't know
their language and how can i find out
what they want of us from creatures who
can destroy me with a breath with a look
will you speak for me for us
she was silent then so faintly he could
barely hear it she said
yes
then make ready to travel with me we
leave by fourth hour of the evening my
people will bring you to the ship i
thank you and i thank you tanar
and
what's going on there
so
lebanon has said a number of different
things in that first of all we're
dealing with very dangerous creatures
they could destroy me just by breathing
i'd like you
young woman to go and talk with them in
my place because maybe they'll talk to
you maybe you can find out what's going
on
it's going to be incredibly dangerous
and what we see
is that tahanu
is not so much afraid of the danger of
the dragons it's more that she
just doesn't know what she is
able to do whether she'll be able to do
anything helpful
tenor of course is quite afraid and we
find out
tenor has a dream
she lay awake in the wide bed and saw
before her mind's eye over and over
again the same scene erode and tahanu
walking on it alone and a knot a net a
black writhing coiling mask descending
from the sky dragon's swarming fire
licking and streaming from that at her
her hair burning her clothes burning no
tanner said no it will not happen she
would force her mind away from that
scene until she saw it again the road
and tahanu walking on it alone in the
black burning knot in the sky coming
closer we know that dragons actually do
in fact
prey upon each other because
in the
uh third book when they were deprived of
their speech and rationality that's
exactly what they did dragons killed
dragons and maybe ten our thanks to hanu
will be
killed by these other dragons who aren't
colisene and could be quite dangerous
as a matter of fact the
king will say a little bit later
he's talking to tenar it's she who
protects us he said alone
tener says don't fear for her he says
she is the dragon's daughter the
dragon's sister he she goes where we
can't don't fear for her tanar she bowed
her head in acceptance i thank you for
bringing her safe back to me
for a while
and
this is after
tahanu has had her first encounter with
a unfamiliar dragon this is
on the isle of havnor and what we find
is she is along with the king
and
calls down a dragon from the sky
tahanu raised her good hand pointing
look she said look a spark from a
bonfire a burning cinder rising over the
black line of the pass an eagle of
flames soaring a dragon flying straight
at them tenor stood up in her stirrups
and let out a piercing scraping cry like
a sea birds or a hawk scream but it was
a word one word
medau
the great creature drew nearer with
terrible speed its long thin wings
beating almost lazily it had lost the
reflection of fire and looked black or
bronze colored in the growing light mind
your horses tahanu said and just then
lebanon's grey gelding saw the dragon
and started violently he could control
it but behind him one of the other
horses let out a nay of terror and he
heard them trampling in the hand
handler's voices again tahanu cried out
that word the dragon veered in its
flight slowed came on stopped and
hovered in the air about fifty feet from
them
tahanu called and the answer came like
an echo prolonged mad
what does it mean lebanon asked benning
to onyx
sister brother
the wizard whispered so this is a
greeting a
evocative saying oh sister brother kin
kin of mine
i'm greeting you i'm recognizing you and
it's going both ways
and what we see is the dragon
connects up with
and talks with
tehanu
so there's a brilliant description here
so hanu was off her horse
tossed the reins to janae was walking
forward down the slope to where the
dragon hovered its long wings beating
quick and short like a hovering hawks
but these wings were 50 feet from tip to
tip and as they beat they made a sound
like kettle drums or rattles of brass as
she came closer to it a little curl of
fire escaped from the dragon's long long
tooth open mouth she held up her hand
not the slender brown hand but the
burned one the claw the scarring of her
arm and shoulder kept her from raising
it fully she could reach barely as high
as her head the dragon sank a little in
the air lowered its head and touched her
hand with its lean flared scaled snout
like a dog an animal greeting and
sniffing lebanon thought like a falcon
stooping to the wrist like a king
bowing to a queen so they are
now engaged with each other and there's
still peril right but what happens is
talking instead of fighting or killing
tahanu spoke the dragon spoke another
exchange of pause the dragon spoke at
length
onyx listened intently onyx can actually
is a wizard knows the true speech that
they're speaking in one more exchange of
words a wisp of smoke from the dragon's
nostrils a stiff imperious gesture of
the woman's crippled withered hand she
spoke clearly two words
bring her the wizard translated in a
whisper
and then the dragon takes off
the wizard says it called her daughter
of the eldest and they find out from
what's actually going on the dragons are
angry we also find out
that
irian is being sent for and will
be coming shortly
to
um
parley
and so
this is is where
uh the dragon shows up warm irian and we
have an exchange now
between tenar and orm aryan who's going
to play a very important role
here we go
the dragon had a lighted on the pavement
and was furling its wings with a loud
metallic rattle as the king came out
where it came down its talons had
scratched grooves in the marble that's
how powerful these these monsters are
this
the long gold male head swung around the
dragon looked at the king the king
looked down and did not meet its eyes
but he stood straight and spoke clearly
orum erian welcomed i am lebanon agni
lebanon said the great hissing voice
greeting him as orm embar had greeted
him long ago in the farthest west before
he was a king
onyx and tahanu had run out into the
terrace one guard had his sword out and
lebanon tells him put the sword down and
once again tahanu says that word madaw
sister brother
whispered coming up beside labon and her
gaze unwavering on the dragon
the great creature's head swung around
again in the immense amber eye and a
socket of shining wrinkled scales gazed
back unblinking the dragon spoke
onyx understanding murmured to the king
what it said and tahanu replied
colesian's daughter my sister you do not
fly and tahanu says
i cannot change i am not
that
point in my development and so or miriam
says well should i change and
she says for a while if you will
the dragon turns itself into a
woman
and then they can begin with the actual
conversation she was young tall and
strongly built dark dark-haired wearing
a farm woman's shift in trousers
barefoot the little thing she said in
the common speech and she laughed she
looked at tahani it's like putting on
the shoes i wore when i was five
and then the two women moved towards
each other with a certain stateliness
like that of armed warriors saluting her
ships meeting at sea
they embraced they drew apart and both
turned to face the king so tahanu has
done her task she has
spoken with the dragons at great danger
to herself as it turns out not so much
great danger danger feared but danger
that's not there because she is one of
the dragon kind she is the daughter of
coalescing and they are able to engage
and greet each other but this requires
an overcoming
of whatever fear or reluctance or
dissatisfaction with her own ability to
change
and uncertainty about her own capacities
this is tehanu
in effect truly coming
of age through taking on these tasks
that lebanon
asks her to
to do
you